we'll turn to the flooding disaster in
the South now with many in hard hit
North Carolina now facing a desperate
challenge tonight the crisis in Western
North Carolina are too many to count
this is a potential historic event with
catastrophic deadly
consequences this is an unusually
dangerous storm that threatens to bring
heavy rain and potentially catastrophic
flooding tonight and tomorrow for
Central and particularly Western North
Carolina this is a record hurricane
hitting this
area very high impacts for flooding
slides we're talking land and mud slides
and also the wind threat this is the
worst thing ever it is the worst thing
ever I don't know if we can rebuild or
be able to come back from this historic
flooding high winds and more heavy rain
are expected as Helen makes its way to
the mountains this morning had a bit of
a power uh blip right there hey
everybody Welcome to LED live we are
going to talk about rescues today we
have some awesome people in the house
from Gideon rescue Luke Corey Meredith I
don't remember the dogs names Kodak and
Minnie Kodak and Minnie are in the house
today what's up Kodak and Minnie we're
going to talk a little bit about North
Carolina and you guys have an awesome
Ministry I mean you're not only there
rescuing people but literally giving
them a a opportunity at Salvation which
I think is is a really cool combination
of things so we're going to get into
this well we want to give him something
of value along with the help right
that's right you have to think about are
you giving them something of of actual
long-term lasting durable value or just
a one time hey here's a meal and done so
yeah there's big difference there yeah
and and from you know iard Brock being
my brother that works with you guys um I
hear over and over with him is like this
window of opportunity that you have and
when people have their whole life swept
away from them literally and
figuratively um you know it's like
they're they're asking questions why is
this happening what is what is beyond
this I think it's a perfect opportunity
to knock on the door of their heart
that's that golden hour that golden hour
and you guys have some awesome stories
so so tell us a little bit about your
team here so because it's only a golden
hour not longer time frame uh that's why
we needed a plane so one of our team
members was like hey I'll fly you in and
God blessed us to be ready for that and
uh he also blessed us with uh Mel and or
Melissa and she brought her dog as well
so we had some more dog and more
manpower for uh doing searches which was
what we did for the first week while we
were there now you know how you guys
obviously have somebody that you know up
there or how how are you rolling into
this environment you're just like you
show up like hey we got some dogs so we
were actually um asked to come in um
from a Handler that um had talked to the
authorities there and the um uh fire
department and um other authorities they
um were on board that she had called
them and we were able to come in and
help them assist in finding Miss some
victims that were actually missing in
the area and did you find any
unfortunately yes that that's got to be
a hard hard hard part of the job but
rewarding at the same time I mean
there's there's there's got to be some
sort of you know I don't want to call it
Joy but it's like you know a relief well
it gives the it gives us the ability to
give families closure yeah and so
whatever we can do to do that um this is
why we do what we do right well it's
it's also really stressful for the First
Responders like imagine you're a
volunteer fire department right so in
that situation only the chief and maybe
the few captains get paid everyone else
is volunteer they're coming
in working like probably 14 hour days on
a volunteer basis and they don't have
the Manpower that it takes to go and
thoroughly search all the areas that
people could be you know and the famil
has got to be like hey when can you know
the area get searched for my families
and that's got to put a lot of pressure
on them so it really is a blessing to be
able to come in take some pressure off
those people and yeah I mean some of the
firefighers were like hey we want to do
that but we need to actually tend to
those that are still living right um
while we also want to respect the family
members that want their loved ones
return so yeah it it's it's hard for
them to balance that yeah it's not easy
at all a dog has a 10 times more smell
than you know if humans you know
actually a lot more and um so they're
able to move in a a speed that a man
just on foot could not right so they're
able to to do a wide variety or wide
area and be able to cover that
twice as fast than any human could right
and these dogs did you have them when
you went to Turkey yeah well mini Minnie
and Dozer so Minnie and Dozer went to
Turkey yeah you know and and those were
amazing stories that came out of your
guys's experience of that but you know
what a what a neat thing that God has
given these animals and that we can work
with them and we can have you know this
kind of like working relationship with
them I think that's so cool yeah and all
of turkey I heard that they only had
like 25 dogs for the whole country wow U
before the earthquake I'm sure
additional teams teams came in with
additional dogs but I mean imagine if
that's your starting point right every
building needs like a dog so right yeah
and how many buildings were there
amongst 10 large population cities that
got hit tens of thousands we needed 20
times more dogs wow wow it was massive
yeah I remember seeing the video clips
of of you guys coming kind of coming
into that environment for the first time
and it's just like where do you start
yeah like what what what building do you
pick to go first and that's why it's so
important to pray honestly so Lord lead
us to the right place and then the
people come and they ask and you're like
okay God's Providence is leading us to
where we can be of help and assistance
yeah so tell me a little bit about um
North Carolina here um set it up with
like a little bit of like what when you
guys first got involved what had
happened you know so once we got flown
in then we were able to uh we went
to the Hickory uh airport and all the uh
helicopters were rallying out of Hickory
North Carolina and so that was how we
actually went from our fixed Wing
aircraft way in to where we specifically
needed to go in the area uh we landed in
Newland we were taken there by some
local volunteer helicopter Pilots that
uh they had a pretty good operation but
what I really appreci about him is that
you know they did this
briefing and then they had this prayer
right at the end and it was like they
knew and understood that uh just because
they had helicopters didn't mean that
that was going to be their source of
power they knew they had to actually
look to God for their source of power
and I was like hey I I like working with
these guys right so what I appreciated
about working with the all these
volunteer helicopter teams was that you
know they're professionals and whatever
it is that they're doing they're not
they're not newbies right these are guys
that fly on a regular basis but as you
can see they all took a moment out and
were very intentional in their
organizational structure to pray and
meaning that they didn't trust just
because they had helicopters that they
would be successful right right and I
really respect that it's like
hey just because you have some really
fancy great equipment and some great
training doesn't mean that you're going
to be able to do the things you need to
do they need they knew they needed to
look to God ultimately right and uh they
were great to work with they were like
hey whatever you want uh we'll fly your
teams in right now if you need two trips
they flew actually two trips one for us
and the dogs and one for our equipment
and it was it was game on that's cool
yeah and now you know these guys are
doing it
voluntarily uh they're not getting paid
to do that they getting reimbursed for
their
gas I don't think so wow you know I mean
like it's not cheap to operate
helicopters no very expensive many
hundreds of dollars or thousands of
dollars an hour yeah and they're running
you know the smallest a day the smallest
ones are 300 an hour yeah uh the 44s
which is the four-seater is around
600ish an hour yeah a big one took us
the bells are somewhere closer to 12,300
an hour or more wow and when you get to
like the Blackhawk helicopter which you
guys have flown in multiple times um how
much is that that's taxpayer dollars
okay that doesn't
count I think that's so cool that is
like a life dream of mine to drive or
fly in a Blackhawk helicopter and my
brother's done it multiple
times yeah so this is the one that flew
Us in it's a it's a bell and uh I think
it's one of their newer airships so I
actually don't even know what it was but
um they're just ready to go work these
guys well they're I'm sure they're a
little nervous it's loud yeah you know
we're wearing earphones and and they're
not that's something that I would love
to be able to get for our our dogs do
they have such a thing yes they do wow
yes they do so if the Lord provides
we'll be able to get that there you go
that's that's cool but you can see the
beautiful North Carolina there yeah yeah
what what people don't really understand
about this disaster
is it wasn't just water it was also wind
mhm so
like with really wet soil it doesn't
take as much wind to knock your trees
down right
so so rain really heavy and then it was
just blowing I mean that's where all the
debris and everything came from that you
saw like the big you know trees and
stuff like that that were mixed with
cars and houses yeah yeah
and it's not easy to like search those
piles when we when we started searching
I mean you're talking to like multiple
large trees smoosh together and really
you can't search those visually and
that's why the dogs are a necessity for
that because the only way that you're
going to search that is take all the
Time in the World to tear it apart with
heavy equipment which how you're going
to get heavy equipment to every pile or
use dog it's not it's not even just um
the wood and the trees and the brush and
the it's cars it's pieces of homes it's
it's it's houses and everything that was
in them people's Liv
wow all shoved in these in these debris
balls so yeah it was quite devastating
just looking at the news footage and
just going wow I mean like where' he
even start it was unbelievable the power
of water right people don't have any
idea yeah in a matter of minutes I mean
it was like one day this this everything
Rose and then it was just like bam you
know what's crazy about that is that was
actually supposed to hit here in
Chattanooga wow and so you know we would
been experiencing probably a lot of this
I mean that River would have probably
overflowed its banks and we' have been
cleaning up all those houses around
there but um it missed us and did this
every water
drainage every water drainage flooded
like big time so it's it's really Broad
in its scope um and it's like if you're
not expecting it and everyone's used to
like their River flooding a little bit
but everyone said yeah this is not what
we expected at all everyone gets caught
off guard by disasters that's that's
right that's a very common denominator
every disaster we go to I mean whether
it was Hurricane Harvey in in Texas and
the guy's like I was carrying my stuff
down the street and lo and behold after
a bit I'm up to my chest in water and
he's like and the storm is hit wow you
know and I'm just like and that's how it
was in you know in this kind of flood
too where you know we saw on Facebook
actually uh my wife she's from this area
and that's her in the picture and we saw
this church that she drives by all the
time and we saw a picture on Facebook it
was there and then it was gone wow and
Jess is like oh like I love that little
church it's like my Landmark you know
wow this is Dozer actually searching
this
debris so you guys are just kind of
roaming around on the banks going up and
down all over these these kind of balls
of
intertwined mess yes so the all the
river drainage has become an area of
high probability so this particular
River area um people were known to be
missing from just Upstream so you that's
where you start and then you work your
way down and you have no idea how much
Downstream you're going to need to go so
you just you start where they reported
missing from and keep going
wow you can see this this person's home
completely destroyed M all of his
cars you know everything's just all this
was underwater at one point yes oh yeah
yeah definitely underwater it's not like
you just move everything you own right
you know I mean you could move a car
right of course you know in these come
situations they actually came in with
some government help finally and um this
was a shnook that was actually bringing
in uh help to places so yeah volunteer
helicopter and government helicopters
were Landing there in the Frank fire
department where we were and uh dropping
off supplies and they turned that into a
pod a point of distribution to where now
all the people in the community that
need goods and supplies are actually
able to uh come to the fire department
and get the food and the water and yeah
as you have to understand right this
time there's still no electricity
there's still no um clean water there's
still no um internet there's no nothing
there's no outside world it right you
know it's you're cut off right but
you're getting donated stuff from all
over and you guys are like um also
Distributing these things as well oh
yeah okay and well I mean they had a
system set up where they were running it
from the fank fire department we were
just volunteering like assisting what
they were doing there you know go it's
important to respect what the locals are
doing right and not come in and be like
oh we know you know yeah we've done this
before let us figure out how this is
done yeah so they did a good job you
know they had many many volunteers at
that fire department
that I remember uh one of our friends
Garrett that came with us on this
response said uh he after the end of a
long day here volunteering at the Pod he
said you know one of the ladies had she
had he's like I assumed that she was a
on the fire department because she had a
firefighter kind of shirt on but she's
like she's like everyone's coming to me
for answers and everyone wants me to
provide Solutions she's like I'm not
even a first responder like I just have
this firefighter supporter
t-shirt right and so like that's the
level of push that's the level of need
and you think yeah your fire department
they can handle it yeah for how long
yeah right you know I mean like these
guys are yeah on it all day every day
for four days five days six days right
without relief but it's even more
complicated than that because at this
fire station in particular they never
had something like this ever the fire
chief's been there 20 30 years and they'
never ever seen it before yeah wow so
he's struggling with how to accept
donations with the culture there most of
them they want to give it to the next
person they won't they don't want to
accept it and also a lot of them
couldn't get to the fire station so we
were on a daily sending out side by
sides and four-wheelers to bring all the
good
to people who needed it m yeah the
people there are absolutely amazing they
they just come together and help each
other and just I mean the love and the
respect that they have for each other
and wanting to do for others even when
they've lost everything was absolutely
beautiful to see how how openly are
people discussing God and and or oh one
pray with people yeah so this is not
like like don't bring that around here
no no everybody was very open and and
and it was it was they they loved the
literature they um very much wanted the
prayers mhm for sure I mean people feel
you feel your need of it more you know I
mean the water came up to the door of
this fire department and it was like
nope no further mhm because this became
a Beacon of Hope and light for their
town and I saw you know the Fire
Department chief was like looking pretty
tired and I was like Hey brother can I
can I pray with you he's like yeah you
know he's like I really needed that
thank you and then afterwards he's like
actually he's like we're going to do
what we should have done a couple days
ago and he gathered everybody up and he
was like Hey we're all GNA pray together
that's cool and then you know we all
prayed and he was like yeah you know
thank you Corey for instigating for
helping us understand our our need for
um for doing that right yeah right yeah
you want the master planner to help you
out here yeah we had to do that every
day and every evening sometimes several
times in the middle of the day yeah yeah
it's awesome these are Goods this is
still fairly early on in the Pod but
this very early yeah so like there was a
lot more stuff when you came right Luke
there was aund times more yeah you
almost couldn't walk in those bays and
most of the fire trucks on the far side
everything was piled between them from
generators to chainsaws to electric and
kerosene heaters pain
heaters and all of this is provided by
the goodness of your average citizen
this is not government supplies not that
I'm putting the government down like
there is a tendency in this particular
response that was a common idea or
thread and it's like oh FEMA's taking
supplies and all we we didn't see issues
or challenges like that yeah people Rose
to the occasion yeah and all of this is
provided by Average Joe citizen cool you
know your your Boys and Girls Clubs your
church group down the street your book
clubs or your landscaping business and
people were driving from out of state
into the state with it yeah and and for
the roads to be either gone and they had
to travel wide and far just to be able
to get in wow so wow that's Kodak yeah
someone lent us this uh side by side and
he says drive it like you stole it like
yeah God provides even to for us so
great that people do that you know these
things aren't cheap we nice one cuz I
mean we got dropped off by air we didn't
have ground transport were there but
unless someone like that provided it so
right yeah wow some random Ridge so we
were actually uh asked to search the
area Upstream from this bridge though
this is the starting point of one of our
searches and you know how much Manpower
does it take to adequately search an
area that looks like this because to
search it right you have to look at it
from Upstream look at it from Downstream
look at it from the left from the right
it's like you know in addition to uh the
dogs right there could be something in
the middle of that pile yeah and you can
see that that big long piece I think
that was a piece of a bridge or a house
it was one of the too I you can see on
the right side there the giant steel
beams oh yeah it was a bridge that uh
this was a bridge didn't stand in the
path of water
mhm these people had nice waterfront
property huh yeah yeah and as you can
see what water can do to cars yeah it's
crazy I at one time this was a full
functioning car but once the flood got
through with it it was compact there was
a guy that had a kind of a car
collection so all of his cars ended up
getting washed down the river looking
like this but you have to search every
one of them right you can't just be like
well yeah there's a car because every
one of those represents a high
probability cuz you don't know which
ones might have had someone in it that
got washed Downstream I think this is uh
the town of Newland uh J and I searched
one side of the river and uh Meredith
and Mel search the other side and man
there was a lot of
swamp to uh to trudge through yeah and
you think about all these chemicals and
things that you know in people's homes
that like just settle and you know it's
probably not the cleanest of water right
right this was actually the time that we
had found um
one of the missing
people for she actually lived in the
community so it was a a huge blessing to
be able to find her for them to have
closure
um and we were able to work with this
wonderful task force team that came in
and uh helped us retrieve um the
body this was about a mile and a half
Downstream MH uh from where they found
her for the house was there was a
Mudslide that came down the mountain and
pushed the house into the river like
split it apart oh wow and she was in the
house and she was in one side her
husband and her son was in the other
side and they were the Son and the
husband were able to get out even though
the husband ended up with a broken back
and many broken bones and um uh and the
sun I think was okay just a lot of
scrapes and bruises but unfortunately
their their mom the mom was pushed down
Riv at the house wow it was pretty far
to go upstream or Downstream to be able
to cross the river so they set up a boat
um and they're lining in the boat across
the river back and forth on the Rope
there and the road that you know
provides the only access through this
area is like half there half gone right
you know by the end when we left the
that same road they were shutting it
down on the hour every hour because it
was falling apart uh because they're
starting to rebuild it but then for
anyone trying to get in they would let
one chain of cars go each Direction and
then the whole thing's closed wow so
anyone trying to bring in
Goods bring bring in Goods or equipment
whether for repair or to donate or for
continued search efforts it made it
considerably more challenging that was
at the
very and what two weeks after you guys
were
there yeah then your lineman trucks
start coming in and can't get past them
because they're big and they take up the
full Road there was a point that uh we
were needing to check a certain area
that was Downstream that we couldn't get
to um by um foot or um car so we
borrowed a raft from someone and loaded
a mini up and um we uh these Cory and
you guys just went down the river we
went down the river until we got to the
area then got out on the land and was
able to check all the vehicles that had
been swept away make sure there was
nobody in them right right so that's
Adam Adam Anderson was actually a
graduate of a a college program that
many of us went to uh Union College now
Union Adventist University their
International Rescue and relief program
he had just graduated from that um
applying for medical school now and uh
thankfully he had some downtime between
when he got accepted so he joined us uh
for several days there and I was like
hey man you want to call you know your
college and get him down here he's like
yeah so so they ended up all coming and
providing lots of really good Manpower
and uh they did a lot of help a lot of
good I was really thankful gave him some
experience and and yeah obviously help
and uh Adam got to be their Ops Chief so
they're yeah they're super organized
like that and nice
yeah we we didn't get very far down this
River before the paddles that we that
came with it they were like the cheap
Cheapo paddles and oh yeah little
plastic paddles so so Adam and Cory
became Aver yeah and they built a paddle
nice yeah I'm serious that's why the
picture of me and her sitting in the
boat just like they're over there
macgyvering it out just taking my knife
and cutting up a a branch and and fixing
that paddle W paddle and then we got on
down the river and it worked W that's
awesome but these are cars that you know
we had to check each one and be able to
mark them yeah you don't know if
somebody was in that or they driving
that cross the river you know yeah and
then you want to have a record of what
was searched so you know we tell the
fire department you know this is the
section that we search we Mark all the
cars and so that there's no question and
the public can have the rest assurance
that yeah this area was search was taken
care of uh that appropriate measures
were were able to be carried out that's
kind of something you don't think about
I mean there is so much like just
walking over the land and checking it
all that that has to be done right this
was actually a video of many searching
this vehicle W because I a human eye how
can we really tell what's right what's
inside that fully inside that but with
her nose she'd be able to definitely no
mhm and they're just able to smell
there's a human here well they've been
trained to to to smell them out mhm
that's that same
car you know uh some of these areas got
30 Ines of water wow m 30 inches wow I
mean that's so much that's a lot yeah
and a short period of time yeah and when
you combine all of that with the
narrow um Ravines and areas that it was
flowing through yeah my local search and
rescue team here they went out and they
said there is areas where it's over 50
ft deep because it's so compact
everything comes down the mountain and
then backs up yeah it's like a big
funnel I mean it's just like capturing
all the water that it can and just like
sending it down to to one little spot
yes
yeah so right after searching this we
actually um thought it was probably time
to head up to Creston North Carolina
where my wife is from because lots of
her areas and family and friends are
like hey aren't you guys a rescue why
why aren't you guys up here you know
like we need you and we're like man
we're here at Frank and there's a lot to
do so uh we were just like okay Lord if
you want us to go and like we were
packing up we were going to go and then
like they had another request to go
search another area what was the next
area Frank went up there first and then
you guys also went up there I think this
is the picture of that place yeah we
were we were having to check for a an
elderly gentleman um the whole family
was in this house and but he was
disabled and I guess they weren't able
to get him out before the the mudslide
came and slid that that house is not
supposed to be there it was up high wow
and it had been slid all the way down
and off and it's literally that's a
cliff yeah yeah and so it's hanging on
the cliff and we had to check you know
all around it inside and we went down
the river as well wow um looking for him
but unfortunately wasn't able to find
him wow some of these areas um you know
they no longer have a way in or out of
their house after the flood so like if
you're on the road side you probably
have a way out but if you're on the
other side of the river from the road
you have no way out no you got no way in
or out so we actually we'd load our
packs up with food and water
and deliver them to people as we're
doing the search as well or find people
that needed those supplies and then we
would come back and actually we had um a
group of river guides they formed into a
team and they came up and like hey we
really want to help we've got the boats
we got the skills and it's hard for
those type of organizations to be able
to plug into and find a place to work
because the the federal teams they don't
work like that the state teams typically
don't and so like if they go to your
your EOC Emergency Operations Center mhm
they're not really going to plug them in
because they're not part of their system
that they know and trust and work with
but does the situation need that kind of
Manpower do the rivers need that kind of
additional searching well yes they do
right they've maybe been searched once
by our team but more eyes after more
time has gone by other things get
revealed search it from the water
instead of from the land mhm so we're
like yeah you know you guys could go
search here and there they were so
thankful to be of assistance you know I
couldn't tell them like it's not a I
can't tell you're going to find
something but I could tell you that the
situation is worthy of more attention
and they really appreciated like being
able to find a way to work with the
Frank fire department and the Frank fire
department didn't have to like navigate
that relationship where I could just say
hey these guys are able you want them to
search and they just be like yes yeah
so we we like being able to facilitate
uh those relationships to be able to
happen where we don't have to spend the
manpower to do it but the community
would like to know that those areas are
are are thoroughly searched MH MH
nice and they also took additional food
and supplies to some of the people we
found on the far side of the river as
well and they had more manpower to do it
yeah cuz you could tell them where they
were and like these people over here
need need some stuff yeah yeah
and by doing all of that it it takes a
lot of stress off the fire department
that's never handled something like this
before and they're already trying to
cope with how to process everything
right they're working with people that
need help right now and not like this
like let's just go search and make sure
nobody's over there kind of a thing you
know they're probably dealing with a lot
of other things other Dynamics yeah
leaves them open for that so one of the
guys from this department
um told me that they went on a call and
there's a a woman that needed help and
needed rescuing and he gets there and
they walk up and uh they're about to
throw the throw bag rope like she's
where she could catch it and hold on to
the rope and she could get pulled into
safety they're about to throw it and
they realize that the back ho that
they're standing on starts to shudder
and shake and that's your signal that
it's about to blow out the water's about
to take it Downstream so like we had to
retreat we couldn't throw the bed bag
and we're like ah you know like so close
you have to understand at this time
she's screaming for help yeah right the
water is like Rising right it's like
every second MH and how long can she
stay on right so then they go back next
to like I guess a building and there's
this pile of lumber and wood and then
they get they get ready to throw it
again and that starts shaking and then
they have to abandon that and like just
after they get off like it goes just
like the the BHO did wow and uh he's
like we we got beat back by the flood
and he's like I'm standing there she's
yelling for help and he's realizing
everything I've ever done in rescue he
says I've
had a an an intervention that could be
effective and he's like in this time
there's absolutely nothing I could Doh
and he's like I'm just sitting there and
like I can't do this I can't do that and
it's like he's like all I could do was
pray he said all I could do is like Lord
there is no nothing we can do she's too
far out there the water's too deep it's
rushing too fast and she's like on a
tree you know you're going to have to
save her yeah yeah and he says he stayed
there the whole time with her and she
rode that whole flood out clinging to
this tree and she lived it never broke
free she lived it didn't break free she
didn't get washed off and he was just
like the Lord answered my prayer wow he
said that there was absolutely nothing
anybody could do he's like we almost
lost our fir truck you know like wow so
when we ask he answers that's right
that's right beautiful huh it was it was
therapeutic for him to be able to share
the story you know I bet this was a one
time we had to go
Downstream these um Sheriff uh deputies
were actually um being very generous and
giving us a little walkway to get across
nice so um that's what that was
nice it's just endless it is you know we
we would go from one site to another and
you you know you spend quite a while
driving there and like it gets dark
while you're searching and it's just
hours and hours yeah yeah endless you
see how tall the debris piles oh yeah
are you know we're talking I don't think
that one that's a 20 foot tall debris
pile and water was in this whole area oh
it was up it was up that far wow this is
a wide broad area too this is like
hundreds of yards across from left to
right that was filled with that volume
of water right and you know what a
hopeless feeling like if you're you know
family member or something is out on a
tree out in the middle of me what do you
do right you
know
wow I'm surprised more people don't get
hurt in these things to be honest it it
really is miraculous that um you don't
see the loss of life that you would
expect to
see
break all right I can do
this all
[Music]
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's the
mean oh thank you you know we're all
made with a unique fingerprint we're all
God's artwork wow where'd you get
it lightwear wear your
[Music]
witness after doing all these searches
one thing that you know I was really
thankful for is the ability to go from
these searches right up to Creston where
my wife's family and neighbors and
they're all from that were asking for us
to come help and then Luke was able to
come praise God with Mike and some of
our other teammates and Garrett and um
how did that go once you arrived so once
we got there with their culture um they
consider themselves mountain people and
they don't trust or accept Outsiders
very easily they don't like to accept
help so they
appreciated that the first team was
there later on at one point um one of
them asked me pulled me aside in the
fire station one of the firefighters
he's like how are you here like why are
you why are you right here like I
explain like did you go through the COC
like who sent you
here and I was able to explain like we
were told to go to the Newland fire
department which is where we went first
and we got there at I don't know 8 8:30
at night and they're like no the Frank
fire department needs more help so we
loaded back up and went there
so like honestly it's God I I don't have
a better answer for you like there's
no there's no other answer like there's
cuz he's like of of all of the places
between here Georgia East Tennessee
South
Carolina like why are you at our little
station right
here and you know it's a real blessing
to be able to say in all
Verity right we're here because God sent
us specifically to you in his Providence
because he cares for you yeah he cares
for the struggle that you're going
through the the problems that you need
solutions for yeah God cares about and
that's the real reason why you're there
I mean honestly like you know it's like
you're there to help and you're there to
do this but you know I think just to
show that God is also taking care of
this issue at hand yes to show that God
still loves them that's right that's
right this was a resident um he actually
was a firefighter in the U Newan uh fire
department and he just gave a a neat
little testimony of how bad it really
was but hello um these fine folks has
came to help us and it's pretty
devastating uh we got hit by the
hurricane um
and lots of people lost their
lives and we've got a lot of people
still
missing and it's it's been rough but
everybody's coming together working
together amen and uh that's what it's
all about to try to help everyone so
everyone's safe and um doing all we can
do amen amen insect of the communities
here and great greatly yeah and it's
going to take years to rebuild and many
years yeah it it's forever changed the
landscape it really has would you say
it's probably the most historic thing
that's happened oh most
definitely and nothing touches it that
you know of in history so far no wow
it's never seen anything like
it 22 Ines of rain in less than 12
hours wow and that's just unheard of
that's something don't
well God bless you we're praying for
you it's like the clouds just opened up
and just in one spot yeah wow and people
are looking for like why is this
happening right you clearly see it on
their face like this has not been
anything we've ever experienced before
right yeah what's the reason for this
and you know that really is part of like
what is the value of what you bring to
the table when you come to this right
people are asking that they may be
asking it only here and not here right
but to be able to come to them and say
hey this the the theme of evil versus
good that story is wrapping up and as
Jesus said in Matthew chapter 24 you'll
have fires floods
pestilence disasters right Wars these
are all signs that he's coming soon
right and we don't know the day we don't
know the hour but we can know that it's
soon we can know the season right and so
this is the season that uh that Christ
is coming soon and that now is the time
and of our opportunity our Power of
Choice God's given to every one of us
the power of decision and choice and you
know how life is like you get busy you
get distracted you get about your
business you got to earn the money you
got to take care of your
responsibilities and God can get pushed
off on that back burner MH and the
disasters can as bad and as evil as they
are they can help us rethink right they
put it back Forefront like what's the
bigger picture here reevaluate yep and
say I maybe need to actually give time
and attention and thought to my walk
with God and things of Eternal
importance yeah yeah amen amen but how
much do you actually need to be able to
respond in in this whole area from North
Carolina all the way down to Central
Florida how many churches do we
have a lot probably a lot oh man there's
got to be a lot here in the Bible Belt
there's got to be hundreds yeah maybe
more yeah there's 28 in this local area
here so I'm sure that's a good two hour
span right there m and that's just one
area 90% of what we're doing there's no
special training that's needed is are
you willing but not only that do you
trust God to provide for what needs you
have because where we were at in in
Frank North Carolina there was a group
from Alabama a group uh me from
Tennessee another one from Colorado a
couple more from I think New Hampshire
but it it doesn't take that how many how
many churches are closer M it it we're
happy to help but there's so many more
that can help and it's not comp
a lot of them are helping you know like
a lot of these volunteers like they're
not paid staff of the fire department
they're not official volun like before
they weren't official volunteers but now
they are right yes and and I think the
way that you get there is You just prove
your character you get in you get to
work and and that builds that
relationship and shows that you're a
trustworthy individual I mean the reason
why we wear uniforms is so that people
can take us a little bit more seriously
so that when people have to make a a
quick decision about if they're going to
work with us or not that they can say
hey these guys are at least they look
quite intentional they look respectable
enough to probably do the things they're
going to say they're they're going to do
so here's the thing you know anybody can
help anybody in a disaster yeah if you
can give somebody water yep you can help
that's right if you can pray with
someone right you're of help just being
there in their need power yeah the power
of presence is absolutely phenomenal and
situations like this yeah you guys have
seen this multiple times I think that
was the the biggest thing that I
remember hearing out of your your turkey
trip was you know just just even having
the Muslim faith say you know like look
these Christians are coming all the way
over here on the other side of the globe
in my time of need you know what a
beautiful thing and the amazing thing
was is we were able to pray with them
yeah we we were able to administer them
and I think we showed the love of Jesus
to them in a way that they have never
seen before but that's what happens in
these kind of situation it's it's like
an open door God is just opens that door
and you're able to just shine his light
out to them yeah yeah it's one of the
biggest things I think that comes out of
this and I love that you guys are
bringing this out is just like you know
people rallying together coming and
helping and and you know when you bring
God into the situation you're you know
you're bringing in power that that is
unexplainable why did this person live
how had this situation happen like we
almost lost our firet truck but but this
tree held you know it's like that's only
because of God that's right but even as
they were praying in in Turkey the the
Muslim families that we're praying with
they held their hands out as they pray
also out of respect for us beautiful
yeah yeah it was beautiful you know
there's uh the standard perspective is
and it's it's the perspective of the
government the government knows that
when the disaster hits there's going to
be good people to come and there's going
to be bad people right and uh people
that want to take advantage either by an
illegitimate relationship of of like a
contract to cut someone's trees up or
something like that and they charge too
much or maybe don't do a very good job
or don't complete the job they know
that's going to happen they all know
there's the potential for looters and so
the standard status quo answer is we
don't need anything if we need you we'll
call you right right right because they
want to and there's a need there's
legitimate there's a legitimate purpose
and function of the government right M
we're not anarchists right
but the perspective of the government is
a valid one but is it should it also be
the only perspective MH should it also
be the perspective the the church or
followers of Christ automatically by
default accept that that okay we'll only
respond if if if the government requests
us no way we never be there you won't
ever get to respond that's right yeah
and they won't get the help they need
right not only that like where we at in
Frank because of their culture they're
not going to accept it they're going to
say no this guy needs it more or she
needs the help more right and so once
you're there and you're helping out I
didn't go on almost any of I didn't go
on any of the calls I was at the fire
station the whole time but I saw stuff
things that needed done whether it's
parking cars yep it just keeping the
parking lot but I did it without asking
yeah it's just looking for something
that needs to be done and doing it y
it's it's really as simple as this and
people off they always ask what skills
do I need to be H you know like here's
the skill you need you need to be
willing to serve yeah because it's as
simple as people who are willing to be
helpful will be helpful right if you
came there to loot well what are you
going to do yeah you're going to loot if
you came there to help people what are
you going to do you're going to help
people right it's as simple as this and
so like we make all these complex well
you know if you're if you're not an
authorized person to come you're just
going to be part of the problem you're
not going to be part of the solution
you'll be in the way you'll be taking up
resources it's like no it really is as
simple as if you came to help you'll
probably find a way to be of help yeah a
simple phrase that I learned in um
working in production and television is
going to be helpful yeah I mean that's
like the bottom line it's like that that
relays to the people like what do you
need done you know what I mean like
whatever it is you'll you'll get asked
yeah so who's this Luke that is the
Deputy Inspector General for North
Carolina he looks pretty happy to be
working with one of our uh veteran team
members there yeah he was at Samantha
and I don't know if Samantha or Amy but
one of them was able to give him a great
controversy shortly there either I think
just after this picture was taken very
cool well he looks pretty happy about it
awesome so we were really thankful that
Luke and and other other of our team
members could come and continue the
mission here at the Frank fire
department but we also needed to go up
to Creston and praise the Lord right
when we got to Creston we had people
calling us being like hey we heard
you're a team in the area can we give
you supplies to give out and we're like
no we didn't really plan on that but uh
okay so people the trailer started
coming and uh one of Jess's friends
Linda had a barn there at at an
intersection where people commonly you
know has a lot of traffic so we turned
it into our own little point of
distribution and then we also went in I
think this was in the area of trade
North Carolina it's the name of the town
there and this old lady didn't have uh
Power and uh one of the things was
dinner was was given was uh these
generators you can see her disbelief
she's pretty I love it and and and you
know Arms Wide Open just like wow what
are you people doing here and where did
you come from thank you for helping yeah
she know has no longer has a way to
drive up to her house she has to walk
across a little board you know that uh
took her Calvert out but um she's she's
there thankful um and uh this is an
example this is right around the corner
of um my wife's family's house um where
people didn't know
Creston right so like Brushy Fork
area um so it's not anywhere close to
where the the hurricane was supposed to
oh to speak way Inland way Inland yeah I
mean it's kind of a higher elevation in
the mountains area but you can see
there's a lot of damage in the trees all
those trees are broken off like half H
for winds wow yeah so this was probably
a
tornado um it could have been a real
strong StraightLine wind event but
what's under reported or not welln about
this is that it was a very strong wind
event as well so lots of trees down all
over the place I mean you you can see
where the trees were cut you know and
the road was cleared but that had to
have been like loads of work there had
to probably been like a 100 trees across
that road before this picture was taken
oh so we went to work cutting
trees and uh doing service projects so
we had a team with some saws and uh
these saws were donated and they're like
actually if you guys went house to house
with the saws that'd probably be the
best use of them so like praise the Lord
you got new still chainsaws to work that
we don't have to mess with
tinkering uh this guy came all the way
from Australia to help us yeah I love it
Michael yeah his wife Den Den's man
right here he he jumped in there and is
uh out there volunteering it's awesome
you know he had a way with people where
you could just walk up and start a
conversation and they felt at ease with
our team you know doing these service
projects for free like we were became
friends right away and he just was
really able to to form those
relationships this is the guy that we
were cutting for and he had his own
chainsaw he's like actually he's like my
chainsaw won't cut straight because the
bar is bent he's like I need what you
guys here with your big chainsaws you
can cut the bigger stuff and we spent
quite a bit of time awesome at this
place awesome so who who all are you
focusing on on witnessing to and helping
oh I mean everybody that needs it you
know is it is it just the people there
locally oh no well I mean I the people
that give the supplies they like to hear
the stories of you know what those
supplies went towards they like to see
that you know their chainsaws went to
use and or even other volunteers that
come in from all over the place but
seems like you have a thought on your
mind there like go ahead and share
it no you're you're sharing it um we had
uh once we got there they had switched
roles somewhat to doing a lot more house
calls and medical calls so some of the
nurses that would come out um they were
also volunteer and it's two three hour
drive for them to come out and
volunteer and they came out um one of
two of them came out uh twice and then
one of them came back a third time with
her
daughter but even just last night after
after deing slash right at the end of of
uh the presentation I gave she was
asking me how it went and she was
actually wanting to drive out and come
see
it and um she she's looking to expand
her knowledge of of Christ and how how
to show his love oh yeah but she wasn't
even affected by by this she was just
another first responder there so it's
not only about the people that lost
something it's also about those that we
working
with right we're able to wit so those
those that are served along with us to
be able to give them the Hope yes uh
give them maybe some of the mission and
direction as far as like hey this
is this is the how and the why it's
going to work and it brings up one of my
favorite points and that is you know
Romans 1:16 says I'm not ashamed of the
power
or I'm not I'm not ashamed of the gospel
of Christ for it is the power of God un
salvation so when you respond to
disasters or do whatever it is that
you're going to do could be doesn't have
to be
disasters do you want just the wisdom
and power of man to accomplish that or
do you want the wisdom and power of God
to accomplish it
because like we don't have the power to
pull this off we we don't have the power
to get the helicopters and you know make
the relationships and and do the
searches and give the supplies all that
stuff we really don't and um we're a
team of the least of the least
essentially we don't have lots of you
we're not the Red Cross we're not um
FEMA we're not Task Force One teams and
we really depend on the power of God to
make it work ultimately because when you
go you you're going to respond in the
power of one of two ways there's only
two ways that you can go one is in the
wisdom of men the other is in the wisdom
of God and the power of man is quite
limited or you know just Humanity the
power of God is infinite so yeah and
this little story kind of illustrates
that we one of our team members locked
their keys out of their car right so we
borrowed this temp pole um these guys
that were camping out there and uh I
eventually we got in right
but the cool thing about that was these
guys that had um laned us their tent
pole they walked up and they were in
these Beaver seits right like uh I was
like what am I what am I looking at
right now bies and uh you know this this
guy on the right brought uh you know his
teenage sons and and the other guy was
was working with him too in the in the
white and pink hoodie there and uh they
had driven for hours and uh they were
helping rip out the floors and rip place
the subfloors of Linda Linda is one a
good friend of Jess my wife and she
taught Jess all about horses and and all
that and now Jess gets a a chance to
repay uh Linda's kindness and mentorship
over the years and so these guys came
and they're professional crew you know
like to hire that team just don't look
at the bu professional you know how much
would it cost you to hire this this full
team to do what they need to do because
they got that job done like really good
and really quick and uh you know they
were enjoying themselves like being able
to wear their Bucky suits up there but
it was just really cool because like we
were able to connect with them you know
as well and uh they're like hey we want
to learn more about you what it is to go
help people in disasters and and give
Jesus away while you do and we like hey
that's great you know awesome so the
people that you meet that are also
servant are like some of the best
relationships you can form and you know
it's the power of God that you know
that you meet a guy you know with his
team there with your Bucky Beaver seeds
and it's the seeds you plant awesome
that you never know come to fruition
yeah it's the Holy Spirit working
through you that that they can see and
it it ends up opening doors down the
road because whether
it's singlefold for just bringing them
to a closer walk with Christ or it ends
up helping us down the road it's awesome
you guys get a to to really see I think
the Practical I mean this is what this
is what God really designed for all of
us right go and help those right I mean
that was the whole idea of like you know
go and sell give to the poor help those
that are in need I mean that's what
Jesus was doing right he's he's running
around helping people in their time of
need and so this being a very extension
of that very practical gospel that God
has you know it's beautiful to see is
that not what we were commissioned to do
that's right right right it's the
humility and the meekness and the love
of Jesus yeah that we can shine to
others yeah self-sacrificing you know
these people are barely sleeping don't
have anywhere to sleep probably most of
the time um no comforts you know and
they're willing to be in uncomfortable
situations to go and help somebody in
their time of need and I think that's
the very heart of the Gospel well they
were camping in a tent you know yeah but
uh you know this tree right here
actually is an another example of the
power of God because it was right next
to the guy's house he's like hey could
you guys cut that tree and I was like I
don't know like it's pretty like if if
we don't do this right this tree is
going to crush your house and I was like
are you willing to take that risk you
know cuz I mean that's significant he's
like yeah if we put this rope on it and
like if we pull I'm was like yeah okay
yeah that'll work and then like there
was just a little little voice being
like Cory put another rope on that
yeah
okay so we had uh him pulling on this
you know rope that he had supplied and
like we had also had this other rope on
it and like I'm cutting the tree and
like I get it and it's it's teetering
you know and like they're pulling on it
so it's pulling it this way and then
that rope breaks and it starts to swing
back to the house and I'm like oh no
this is the worst thing yeah like
possible this is the oldest house in the
county it's like oh no this is this
house is like built out of like giant
Timber beams and he was he gave us this
whole tour of the house and he was like
yeah this is like piece of history and I
was like this tree is about to crush
this house
like but praise the Lord because you
know God was like Cory put another you
know rope on
that uh all the all the people pulling
jumped on the other rope that we had put
on it and were able to pull it away from
the house and it fell and I was just
like oh yeah you know yeah trees trees
will do funny things
yeah yeah so this is Linda this was our
biggest service project there fifth
generation Family Farm um she has two
water drainages that come one on each
side of her property and her her Fields
were just full of debris her her barn
and all of her hay was
flooded her the barn that actually Jess
and I were married in was right there on
her Ranch wow and it was flooded her
house was um was flooded mhm and Bridges
were were gone and her horse her prize
horse they had like won trophies and
stuff survived the flood but it died a
few days
later uh from complications from it it
was it was just so sad you know but Jess
you know was able to be there for Linda
and like God sent like three
construction Crews to redo her
house and like I didn't see that
happening mhm you know and that brings
up one one point that I really want to
make about you know like going to help
people doesn't matter if it's a big
disaster it doesn't matter if it's just
your neighbor you can imagine the time
and the effort that it's going to cost
you you can imagine the the wages that
you aren't going to earn you can imagine
how hard it's going to be to get someone
to fill in your shift and get take your
P or whatever it is right or talking
with your
clients what you can't imagine is how
God is going to bless it in ways that
don't appear to your imagination right
we can imagine the cost we can't imagine
the blessing
right but who gets the blessing yeah you
know I think I think all parties in this
situation get the blessing like not only
is the person that you're there helping
I mean there seeing the people rally
around it and you're obviously you know
speaking about God praying they seeing
you you know act out but but you get a
massive blessing right I mean you're
walking away from this change I mean it
feels good to do something good for
somebody right absolutely and and
especially when you see somebody have
this miraculous like story you guys have
tons of these things but but when you
see somebody like you know that just
seemed utterly hopeless and you come you
know riding in on your shiny new uh yeah
I don't know four-wheeler thingy that
they gave you or whatever steel chainsaw
yeah steel chainsaws and you know it's
like the calvary coming in like you know
and I think that speaks volumes to these
people this is uh what Linda had to say
um after you know all the various
construction Crews have been helping uh
lots of people had been coming out out
what did it mean to you Linda for people
to come help and do you see the hand of
God in their help and
assistance I do at first I thought why
did this happen but it was for a re
because I had such wonderful wonderful
friends J her husband Corey and they
brought their co-workers and they were
God
sent so deeply uh no way I could thank
him enough and the
Gratitude it was from
God yeah you know you never know like
when we get to the end of this thing all
this stuff it's stuff that's right you
know what I mean it's all going to float
burn break and and and not to say not to
put a diminishing on the value of these
things because these things mean things
to people but you know if if if if all
of this that got swept away gave
somebody a refocus or a you know an eye
open to God right you're you're going to
think it's all worth it yeah absolutely
and with that being with that being said
I'm I know we're focused on kind of on
North Carolina but prior to where I came
up from in Florida one of the last
houses we did it was the uh the thrift
store for the town and that was for the
same hurricane right it was it was this
is just
uh two maybe three days before we came
up to North
Carolina and the whole house a large
house um the storm surge had come up to
above above my height level probably I
don't know close to six foot the whole
house and it's all waste deep to deeper
with stuff anything from China to
Furniture to like you name it it's in
there sewing machines mud mud and in
that town most of it's on septic so
there's a combination of mud and
everything else like it was it was rough
cleaning it out and at the end of all of
it the the gentleman asked if he could
pray with
us and he said you know in all of this
I've been here I've lived in this house
50 years this is my high school
sweetheart my wife right here this is
everything we've collected over 50 plus
years I grew up in this
house and we've lost
everything but even now I can see Jesus
working through you guys and I've I've
been able to see Jesus love through you
guys and he started to say it and his
wife started to cut him off and he said
no I'm going to say it he said in in in
all of this I'm thankful right now for
this
hurricane I'm thankful for this because
I got to see Jesus in you he he just
lost everything literally everything we
we probably pulled three to four 40 yard
dumpster full of stuff wow stuff and he
he said all of this it it has no value
yeah knowing you knowing you being able
to see Jesus in you is what really
matters that's right amen right and what
that does is just bolster your faith
bolsters his faith yeah but it's not any
credit to me or to the team I had with
me it's the Holy Spirit working it's not
us in any way shape or form right it's
amongst the the pain and the devastation
and the dark clouds and the storms that
come in our lives y that we see our need
for God more yep and then we can
actually see God work even better yeah
amen amen amen yeah they have to be the
works of God if there are Works they
nothing how's that going to stand on the
day of judgment can I bring my works
right no you know it has to be the work
of God so if it's the work of God I've
got no ability to think highly of myself
in it right it's got to be got to be the
works of God it's definitely not our
work it's just our cooperation with the
Living God and I think a lot of people
are going to be like God when when did I
help you when did I do this right oh
well you know like these disasters right
here and you know I sent you to that
house and and and and that was you know
what you did for that person you did for
me you know I think there's going to be
a lot of people who who did it just
because they feel the burning desire in
their heart to go and help you know but
didn't really fully even understand it
you know I definitely feel like in in
every disaster that we go to in in
whether it be turkey or here in the
states North Carolina you know you can
just see the hand of God moving in every
step but that's why I say that the power
of prayer is so powerful yeah because it
if it's not by prayer we are not able to
have the Holy Spirit to be able to help
us move and go exactly where God wants
us to go yeah yeah beautiful yeah these
people uh I mean you're looking at
people from the dtas Oklahoma
Tennessee um we had some people come
from like New Hampshire I think it was
and Pennsylvania uh Union College came
from
Nebraska I mean this is this is a lot of
people all showed up here at um at her
place I I know some other people came
from Georgia and uh you know is it worth
the effort and the expense to do it yeah
absolutely right but with that being
said how often are those expenses
covered God always provides it's not
always but I would say more often than
not well yeah in my case God has always
provided in one way or another yeah it
may not be monetary but he provides yeah
you know there there's been a few times
where we have had to put like a large
amount of money up front in order to
pull off a response but God's been very
faithful so that if that was the case he
he pays us back on the next one to where
it does work out financially right right
to where right you don't even know in
what ways that God is even taken care of
you and I think that the thing here is
is obviously like not like okay God when
am I going to get my payout the thing is
is like God will literally work in your
life and in your time of need you know
what I mean you don't even know what's
disaster's coming down here that you're
going to be a part of that you're going
to be needing some serious go help from
God and and and you know what I mean
like only in the wake of Eternity are we
going to look back on this and be like
wow because I did that and helped there
God was just like Mighty in this area
over here so you know yeah we won't even
know the seeds that that were planted
and and how they come about later on yep
it'll be amazing to see in heaven yep
you guys are awesome man I absolutely
love hearing all your good of stories I
thank you for coming and and blessing us
I know you're you're you're you're off
to go talk talk at a youth rally right
now so um I can't keep you too long but
um thank you for bringing the dogs thank
you for bringing the stories thank you
for bringing the the encouragement and
the joy and let me tell you guys if you
guys have two fingers maybe even one
finger you can help you can help right
here that's right you can call your you
can call these guys or look them up and
uh you know we'll put their Link in
their description below but if you want
to get involved trust me every single
time every single person I've ever heard
that goes on these trip with you guys
comes back absolutely changed and
blessed and I know that that is the that
that is the thing so if you want to see
the actual hand of God working in
reality and a lot of kids these days
they go I don't see God I don't hear God
here's a way that you can hear and see
God immediately like he works in every
single one of these times so I'm sure
these disasters are going to get more
and more they're not going to get less
and less so check out Gideon rescue
check out all of their their videos
they've got an awesome YouTube channel
as well and um they got a lot of content
of some of these stories on their
YouTube channel so um thank you guys for
coming and I can't wait to hear your
stories in the next one thank you for
having us yes thank for having me
blessing if you like this video like
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
so you know when we launch new videos
and drop a comments below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can
what say that again
how no I don't know what to say
[Music]